rescue workers in Indonesia expect they
will find more victims of a deadly
weekend tsunami crews are frantically
searching the western coast of the
island of Java more than 280 people are
known to be dead and many more are
missing Barry Petersen is in London
monitoring and the search and the threat
of even more damage Barry good morning
good morning
well the coastlines of Indonesia are big
tourist attractions the beaches were
packed the hotel's full the nightclubs
hopping and all of a sudden nature
struck the fun of a Christmas holiday
turned into tragedy the rockband 17 was
between songs when at 9:37 p.m. the
tsunami brought death without warning to
band members and the group's manager
were killed lead singer Ethan was swept
out to sea grabbed a floating box and
made it back to shore but his wife Dylan
shown together on a recent trip to Paris
is still missing
alais he posted this video I pray he
said that my wife is fat
five-year-old Ali was among the lucky
pulled out of a wrecked car amid a day
of frantic searches often by hand
clawing through the debris experts blame
this volcano in the same area as the
infamous Krakatoa that erupted more than
a century ago this one has been erupting
for months a landslide
might have triggered the tsunami but
Indonesia's tsunami system was designed
to send alerts only after an earthquake
and worse officials have now admitted it
has been out of action for six months
because of technical problems and
vandalism over the Christmas holiday
tourists flock here and locals make
their money we were all set up for the
holiday said rainy a beach vendor now
it's all destroyed what am I going to do
she asked how will we rebuild
and while it looks like no one could
survive all of this there is still hope
says Red Cross workers Cathy Mueller it
is the rainy season here so there's
always the possibility that if someone
is trapped that the rain is trickling
through and they're able to to take the
raindrops of water that are coming
through and this is not over there are
high tides until Wednesday and the
volcano is still active still erupting
that means another landslide could
trigger another tsunami and this area
now crowded with rescue teams could be
hit again
Adriana Barry thank you it's just such
an awful year for the people of
Indonesia the second tsunami this year a
plane crash
earthquakes thousands have died already
in 2018 no warning system at all that's
what this type of tsunami yeah I mean
you cannot imagine what that moment
would be like the pictures there that
the band on that stage the fear that
must have gone through people's minds in
just a split second to that of night
yeah